welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and new looks at Daredevil Born
Again revealing a new girlfriend with
ties to killgrave and a doomed fate in
the comics also the return of Nelson
Murdoch and paig and hints that meril
candidate Wilson Fisk is going to use
metaverse AI technology to destroy our
lives we're going to dive deep into Matt
Murdoch's sexual history and look ahead
to the next weekend's big super ble
trailers in this episode of the sneak
peek where we look ahead to the future
of fandom and joining me today is
co-host Jessica
hello hello hello hello is it official
now that Matt Murdoch is the Kiest
Avenger I think he is the Kiest well we
don't know if he's an Avenger he's the
he's definitely the definitely the Kiest
Defender 100% he's absolutely Kiest
Defender um yeah he's avenging a sexless
MCU for the bulk of his history look
here we're getting close to Valentine's
Day as a single lady I'm I love him I
respect him and if Matt Matt Murdoch is
listening please marry me
uh immediately leave the girl that
you're kissing in these photos and kiss
me instead well he won't have to leave
her if you know her comics history
yikes uh hey before we get into it we
have a live show coming up on February
15th that is a the day after Valentine's
Day where you can come uh just chill out
with us we're G have a lot of fun
talking about whatever gets revealed at
the Super Bowl we're gonna talk about
Madame web we're going to take your
questions we're going to do some bits
that we never get to do on YouTube it's
going to be at brain Studios on Fairfax
in Los Angeles it's an awesome venue we
had such a great time last time and we
hope you come have a great time with us
this time yeah I heard Jessica Clemens
will be there I heard Jessica Clemens
will be there too I heard that they Ed
like a very very recent uh head shot why
would you bring that up right now you
know I'm sensitive about that head shot
you look great that head I don't and
when Riley Riley our post supervisor
said oh Jessica you look exactly the
same I look better now get rid of that
photo well whichever version of you you
feel better about that's what you look
like and I look like a
baby keep going keep going when when I
was uh I you know I was in college I
wrote for the newspaper in town and I um
I got I was like a columnist and my
editor at the time was like Hey so we're
gonna put we can get like a thumbnail of
your face and I was like o I'm like
Roger eert so I submitted a photo that
was like just us goofing around after
improv rehearsal and I just I thought I
looked pretty good in the photo so I
sent it to my editor and she just emails
me back she go goes is this a recent
photo and I was like yeah we took it
like last weekend and she goes okay and
then it prints and then all of my
friends read my column and they're like
you look like you're eight years old in
this photo you're like it is a recent
photo it was I just I guess the lighting
was weird my mom said it was a good
photo my mom my mom thinks I'm cool what
a handsome young man you are you have to
use this photo I was standing beside
like crayons with my foot up on a
stool that's a why you weirdo anyway
okay so let's dive into this main topic
about jille Born Again set photos are
coming out and spoiler warning for daril
born again but if you're on Twitter
you're seeing this stuff so whatever um
it's out there it's I don't think
they're trying to hide it this much uh
and what's fascinating about Daredevil
born again is they are completely it
seems like re-shooting this show like
there is a version of Daredevil born
again so any set photos that came out in
like 2022 or 2023 ignore them because
they're re-shooting everything and this
is the version of the show we're getting
now and it's basically going to be a
season 4 of the Netflix stal continuity
from the Netflix run and that includes
we're getting um Point Dexter Ben Point
de uh Dexter Bullseye back on this show
it's just continuing the events um so uh
yeah but here are the updates that we've
seen from these photos and they're
fascinating first off not too
controversial we're seeing some photos
of Charlie Cox with Elden Hinton and
Deborah and Wolf coming back as foggy
Nelson and Caren and Paige and we're
seeing their law practice office Nelson
Murdoch and Paige continuing the little
cocktail napkin where they wrote this
out their dream has become realized and
uh Karen paage is now a partner in their
law office after becoming like a rapidly
successful newspaper journalist working
for the bulletin in the Daredevil show
now she gets to be a lawyer but hey good
for her yeah I'm like uh I call it
nepotism um I'm just in love I'm in love
with Matt Murdoch and I want to be in
there too uh I could a journalist I
could do it hey can we uh can we divorce
the definition of nepotism away from
just friends or people who have
experienced working together people are
like oh you're friends with them so it's
nepotism it's like no nepotism just
refers to if you are blood rated to
someone and they were not at all qualif
is there a definition of nepotism that
does strictly say it has to be family it
has to be like blood related I think
it's supposed to be family but people
use it for like oh they're friends or
they are um married to each other um but
like if they are qualifi if then it's
not nepotism technically
dictionary.com I said dictionary
dictionary.com says the practice among
those with power influence of favoring
relatives friends or Associates and
that's the thing friends or Associates
that's I'm saying let's redefine it
because sometimes you can be friends or
Associates with someone because they
have mutual shared experience with you
in the field that's true it's like well
that's different that's a difference
that's a difference that is the
difference that can diagram it of being
like well if this person there's friends
of mine that I would never hire period
they would be horrible at jobs but then
there's some that I'm like oh no they're
already in this field they're doing
really well they know what they're doing
if they're qualified it's not nepotism
yeah let's just say that there you go we
also see some newspaper headlines and to
me these are the most interesting ones
because if you look at this it talks
about Wilson visk Marl run uh if you
look at this headline on the side it
talks about this like metaverse that's
taking over uh all of society and they
have this whole weird it's probably you
know the copy of the article itself
probably not important but the headline
I think is important uh because we just
saw Wilson FK on Ekko using this
augmented reality to do ASL
interpretation so it sounds like he has
a division of his Fisk Empire that is
dealing with technology and that's going
to be like his whole uh Mo now as a
villain in the MCU imagine him tied with
Team Mysterio and how they use Ai and
fakery digital fakery and and and fake
news to prop up their disinformation
campaign and that seems like exactly
what's going to help Wilson F become
mayor especially if he's rigging the
election it's like yeah technology is
working in his favor the also the
Netflix's uh Netflix's Marvel projects
love doing this and I I I really like it
during like uh Luke Cage a lot of it was
during like the black lives matter
situation of like oh what's going on and
all these things that are happening that
systemically like racism going down to
Luke Cage that's why he was like I'm
going into politics I need to go help
and do something here and then now with
the AI situation with the strikes and
how we all are feeling with AI and how
it's taking over and here is Wilson fist
being like I'm also a villain that's
gonna incorporate this into my life yeah
doesn't it seem like he could be part of
a Marvel
intelligencia and that Samuel Sterns
could be part of this they are all using
like uh like digital fakery um deep
fakes Ai and all this stuff to just like
spread disinformation out there and
cause chaos and that's going to be a big
part of Captain America Brave New World
yes they're Joe uh Jonah Jameson they're
and no way home they are literally just
political fig not even political digital
political figures doing things online
and massing it out blowing it out and I
mean that's how he got it in the comics
was like people were like oh he's
approachable he's a guy that knows what
it's like to be for the people and I'm
like you guys read the big p like the
big picture right now Wilson Fisk is a
horrible person uh yeah either way some
other people confirmed to be part of the
show it sounds like Royce Johnson might
be coming back to play Brett Mahoney of
the show um and then uh you know from
these set photos we're also seeing a
possible white tiger villain committing
a crime of some kind but it kind of
looks like a bootleg version of white
tiger I don't know if it's the white
tiger who wears like the amulet to the
fair family heirloom who's like a super
soldier it kind of seems like someone
who may just use the moniker of white
tiger um the Marvel villain Muse is also
rumored to appear on the show we haven't
really seen this yet this just kind of
rumored um but someone who might be a
major player especially since they're
involved in the Wilson Fisk mayor Fisk
comic story line uh this is someone who
makes art depicting their victims Muse
he's like um Banksy
yeah but also Charlie Cox has seen on
Set uh giving some kisses to Margarita
leier who is playing Heather Glenn who's
Matt Murdoch's current girlfriend but in
the comics brace yourself Heather
Glenn's father is Maxwell Glenn who who
is kind of this head of uh of Glenn
Industries who is mind controlled by the
purple man kill grave who we just talked
about is the best villain to come out of
the Netflix Marvel World
Jessica and why would you do that I'm
sorry you know I don't Maxwell Maxwell
Glenn uh takes his life but also Heather
at the end of her story that happens to
her as well and the thing is you know
damn well Daredevil's gonna probably get
that dark uh it's gonna get really sad
and it's gonna be horrible and it
wouldn't I I think not I I don't want to
see it period clearly it's very sad but
I'm like if they do bring in that
killgrave had some ties to her in the
storyline it again bring in we Jessica
Jones and I could see it happening I
could see them doing it keeping it so
what do you think is more likely on uh
this upcoming season of Daredevil born
again that we will see The Return of
David Tenant as uh as killgrave even
though he died at the end of Jessica
Jones his voice kind of returned to to
Jessica Jones in the finale of of season
3 of that show or are we going to see uh
establishing Wilson Fisk as like someone
who has this specialized form of AI
technology uh in the metaverse and he
uses that to corrupt and erode uh
honesty and Truth in the MCU 100% that
100% that we're getting into the Marvel
Spotlight grounded stuff I'm like oh
100% we got to get it where it hurts
we're doing magic we're doing all these
other things in space we might as well
stay grounded with taking over
technology the the easiest way to take
over the mindes is through technology
see that's why I think like you know I
had a theory a video that came out uh
last weekend or whatever where I talked
about the theory that Wanda may have
said no more mutants in the past and
that like mutants just kind of like
their ex Gene became dormant in a
reality warp and that since then since
her departure in multi ver of manness
that mutants X genes are now becoming
awakened again but that people are still
just kind of confused what the past is
in the MCU I think the the whole idea of
the metaverse and uh fake news in the
MCU could have contributed to this and
this is why people are just you have
this you have Doctor Strange's Runes of
cough call spell that erased
Spider-Man's memory from existence Jes
like you just have I think this General
State of euphoric confusion in MCU and
that fake news is explo this and that
that's how Wilson Fisk is able to like
rewrite his own narrative from Like a
slumlord Villain to being a possible
White Knight to save the city it seems
it just seems like all of that happening
at once should melt people's brains at
some point to a degree that in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it turns them
into something um whereas in today we're
like oh kids are robots or zombies with
their phone and the MCU uh what's the
higher form of that they just be like
dead cuz I'm like if we're controlling
them with spells and with that like
what's the aftermath I think you you
just have people who are confused who
are angry who just don't care I think
apathy and vulner vulnerability to to
savior
complexes um like I'm just surprised we
haven't seen like Mass Cults in the MCU
of people who just and maybe that's what
kingpin's going to be there's going to
be like a cult of Kingpin to where
people are just like okay here's someone
I know someone I think is trustworthy
and then yeah you have cult movements
for him from there well 100% because
once he goes up to that power there's no
one else that's gonna once he's in the
political form there's still the
underground crime ring that's now just
like who's in charge who's doing what so
there's going to be different factions
of New York again where people are just
gonna be going crazy and you choose a
side and God knows what's gonna happen
when Harlem fights the Hell's Kitchen
I'm trying to think of all Burrows in
New York and I can't think of them but
yeah it'll it'll create some cast
Manhattan Brooklyn Queens Staten Island
yeah and they're all gonna fight the
Bronx oh
oh you're from Florida I think I think
those are the five you're from Florida
you don't know New York you don't know
where I'm from you don't know you don't
know where I'm from yeah you know I
think right now would be the time when
Hydra could have a Resurgence like Hydra
being was something that was like
between movies in the MCU you had Hydra
make their big comeback in Captain
America win Soldier and then like nine
or 10 months later they were done in Age
of Ultron uh or it was about a year
later like yes this was explored in
Agents of Shield and it was explored in
some Prelude Comics but like we needed
to see how dangerous Hydra could be in a
movie and I think Hydra should come back
now because now people are just confused
it's gonna come back as something else
it's going to come back as something
else and I could see it being brought in
with Wilson fisk's power of te over
technology because he does he's not
smart so he's just funding it and if
he's funding it and it's going on
forever and it's a political funding God
damn we're just gonna bring out the
worst kind of people that are gonna
create the worst kind of Technology yeah
agreed let's take a look at the a week
ahead on new rock stars so we have our
X-Men first Class breakdown that is on
the channel I think now as we speak uh
check it out um we are also rumored to
have a um a announcement of the
Fantastic forecast this week it's we're
not sure for sure about that but um
we'll see we'll see uh and then we also
are going to be uh live on new rock
stars on Super Bowl Sunday um the live
stream will happen right as the game
comes to an end but uh if you miss it
after the live broadcast we will upload
that stream as a video that you can
rewatch later on the breakroom channel
so be sure to subscribe both to new
rockstars and the break room and uh
whatever trailers we get during Super
Bowl Sunday um we're going to do our
best to just do reaction video uploads
to them as quickly as we can so we might
get like a Deadpool 3 trailer and any
other trailers we're goingon to have
reactions to those on the new rockstars
Channel but that brings us to our next
topic uh where we're gonna do a quick
little preview of what trailers may be
coming down the pipeline for Super Bowl
Sunday yes um so Jessica I'm gonna pitch
you a trailer and you uh give me the the
chances out of 100% okay that weather
will see it if you're looking for an
easy way to pamper yourself revamping
your daily hygiene routine is a great
place to start and geology is here to
help geology is a 29 time award-winning
skin hair and body care company
recognized in men's health Oprah daily
hype Beast birdie Esquire and GQ geology
products use just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologist for decades
geology can help you fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging and I am
old as hell if you don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30 second quiz right now if you
use code new Rockstar 100 geology will
give you 100% off of their awardwinning
skincare trial set 100% 100% that's that
that that's all of it that's all of the
that's the the entire enchilada you also
get an additional bonus offer of up to
30% off one skin hair or body products
when you add it to your trial so 100%
off plus an addition 30% off hope you
save some champagne because this is a
deal we're celebrating click the link in
the description or go to G
l. rockstars 100 to get started I'll
start with one we're highly anticipating
seeing Deadpool 3 100% yeah 100% I think
we're seeing that as well also expected
a trailer for a quiet place day one yes
I think we're seeing this too so I'm I'm
really excited about this movie that's
coming later this year I believe it's
coming in April or May or June the quiet
place yeah are you a quiet place fan I'm
a huge fan I've seen yeah uh the first a
quiet place I think was stronger than
the second one but I I mean John krinski
did a great job directing both those F
he did the damn thing I love a quiet
place I'm OB Killian Murphy
unrecognizable in the second one he's
got that big bushy beard but he's great
the only thing that doesn't make sense
is like why I know this is the premise
of the movie but in a world where you
have sound based uh aliens that are
hunting you why would you choose to have
another kid this is the same debate and
it's it's when it's when the the reality
meets media uh because it's the same
situation I had in The Walking Dead
where I was like girl don't have that
baby I was in The Walking Dead I was
like girl there this is not the time
this is not the time and say and that's
how I felt with a quiet place I was like
you got to put this baby in a a cannon
what was it they built this little
bassinet that was like soundproof in
their basement they took all these steps
but like here's where I get uh and oh
here comes ER talk about how he's dead
again I get there are biological
imperatives and the the biological
instinct to procreate is something that
is very very difficult to resist however
you have two other kids you have two
other kids and your biological Instinct
as a parent is Paramount and if you were
to have a third kid that puts those two
kids at danger oh so the fact that did
that is just Reckless and irresponsible
to those two kids and I can't imagine
that they would still do that you know
damn while John kitki was like not in my
film he said we're having that baby
we're having makes more obviously it's
the whole you know premise of the movie
it makes it an interesting story and and
I get they lost their first kids so
they're like no life must find a way and
we'll do whatever that's the whole point
of the movie but it is just one of these
things where it's like you wouldn't do
that because now every every hiccup
every speed bump is that baby the second
movie every chaotic thing is because of
that baby and I'm like also why wouldn't
they live by the waterfall that's my
thing that waterfall is so loud and they
can talk by it why wouldn't you just bu
what if the aliens eventually showed up
and they just started drinking from it
though then you I don't know I still
think well they' just be confused right
that the whole thing the aliens are just
like thrown by things that are just
natural loud noises like waterfalls
maybe they're worried about the dry
season the waterfall only has like a
trickle during the wet season I don't
know look here let's get back to our uh
trailer prediction uh the movie
Twisters there's a twister movie coming
oh yes there's a twister movie coming
out it is going to be one of the best
movies of Summer it's a sequel to
twister and then uh uh what's his face
uh Glenn what's his face from anyone but
you Glenn Powell Glenn Powell is going
to be in it this GNA be I not know about
there's another twister movie you got to
look into this it's so good I just
looked into oh with Daisy Edgar Jones I
love Daisy Edgar Jones um there's
there's a stacked cast in this what is
going on saying the guy from no what's
going on uhhuh uh-huh everybody's in
this I had no idea of this movie and I I
love twister it's gonna be Bonkers did
you think we were going to get a I
didn't even know this movie was coming
out so do you think we're going to get a
trailer yes because it is a a summer
movie it's coming out July 19th that's
Barbie weekend and you know they're
going to want all eyes on this movie I
think's the studio what's the studio
it's Universal Universal uh production
Universal is paying for a lot of
trailers yeah they love are you sure
okay it's it's amulance so you know
Spielberg passed on this script passed
as in I approve good to go it's gonna be
good oh my God uh so I'm thinking like
80% for Twisters twister trip it's funny
because you know this always happens
Super Bowl Sunday comes and before Super
Bowl we don't really know what the year
is going to look like and then after the
Super Bowl suddenly you know wasn't
there like a Barbie trailer at the Super
Bowl I might be wrong I can't
remember there was a lot of things that
came out last Super Bowl I got yeah too
Twisted by Rihanna Craven do you think
we're gonna get a craven trailer when is
Craven coming out again it got August I
would expect it but do you think it
might take away from Madam web well
Madam Webb comes out before or no yeah I
don't think I I'm going to say because I
think they're want us to focus all our
attention on Madam web right now maybe I
just think the you know the bags are
packed for Madam web we're talking about
like two days before that movie comes
out it's not like a Super Bowl like that
would be a waste of their money to
promote Madam web also like I think it's
a waste of money to also do that Craven
no no no no Aaron Taylor Johnson jacked
all to Hell biting off people's noses
yeah no that's good money to spend super
money on and I think that's why is
because we've already seen such a big
tidbit of that movie that it's like
you're GNA give me a second trailer I
think they would wait a little bit
August is far away I get July but August
we're not going to remember we're not
fair enough yeah normally the Super Bowl
like they they promote stuff that's
coming out for the first half of the
summer um but but we had no I was gonna
say we had Ready Player one and that was
like a March release because I was like
there would have to come out with
another one by Jun June June May and
then July would be all those know the
week before they pull they start giving
you the entire movie fair enough fair
enough that's every movie not just Sony
movies every movie Will a week before
the movie they're like oh here's every
piece of the goddamn film every once in
a while we get a teaser for something
that's coming out way later in the year
uh we're like I'm not going to remember
this come Christmas time but um inside
out too Pixar's Inside Out too it's
coming in June do you think we'll get a
trailer at this we should we should they
they've teased so many times the people
that are coming now the characters they
got to drop it they got got to drop in
now we got enough I don't know my my
wife works on that movie and I do not
know tell Kelly to tell them to speed it
up I need to cry again in a theater
curiosa movie's coming in May we've seen
one trailer do we get a second trailer
at the Super Bowl
H it wouldn't be a teaser no I mean
they'd have to show more but You' have
like Chris Hemsworth in this movie with
the nose the fake nose uh you have Ana
Taylor Joy playing Young furiosa when
does it come out again sorry say again
comes it comes out late may maybe maybe
yeah it's February dude next on our list
Godzilla X Kong the new Empire movie
coming early April yes we are absolutely
getting another another Godzilla X Kong
thing yeah I I think this one will show
more of uh um the the the bad the oranga
Tang it will show more of him than it
did in the tra scar yeah scar thank you
House of the Dragon season two we've
gotten a trailer at ccxp do we get a
second one with a release date o I don't
think so no I don't think so the only
reason I'm saying I don't think so is
because I think uh HBO is waiting a
little bit longer to get more stuff and
they can we're going to tune in
regardless we don't need the Super Bowl
trailer of that to tune in I think we do
just because historically we generally
see some HBO promo this is the only one
uh there's other shows they could
promote but I feel like this is the one
that HBO is going to use to be like
please still subscribe to Max isn't
Larry David isn't Curb Your Enthusiasm
on this last season yeah we might get
like a general HBO promo that has like
it's 30 seconds and we get some shots of
Larry David screaming at a valet and
then Matt Smith going how much younger
can we make
it go to the next one okay on to the
next one I know you want to talk about
this one do we get a teaser for
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice do you think we see a teaser
I
hope it's coming in September sep that's
what I was gonna say I was like it's
kind of far but I feel like you don't
just give us the posters without and
then the name without giving us that's
like giving us Wicked like how Wicked is
doing right now they're giving us a
bunch of teases but they're not giving
us the trailer yet that's why I'm like
Beetle Juice Beetle Juice they're giving
us teases they might as well just drop a
trailer I don't know how far they're
into production though to be fair if
it's coming out in September they gotta
be to be done close to rapping that's
what I thought and Michael Keaton
improvised the entire first movie he's
probably improvising
again that's what makes it so hard to
shoot he does a different take every
time I'm gonna say yes okay say yes um
Joker fol Adu we better I don't think we
will that's not coming until October I
think oh never mind no we're not getting
it yet they're they're GNA keep teasing
us with some behind the scenes footage
or photos same with Venom 3 I don't
think we see a Venom 3 teaser before a
craven before Venom um okay but here's I
think the one we're both most excited
about Wicked do we get a wicked teaser
at the Super Bowl yes we do see I think
that's the holiday release that
Universal's like we will plug one
holiday release and it's gonna be Wicked
and because I think that is of all the
different movies coming out later this
year I think Wicked has the best chance
to make a billion dollars you are so
excited for Wicked and I it wasn't until
like recently where I realized how much
of a fan of wicked you were oh God we
got to find some I mean you put it on
your top five movies of the year and I
should have put it on mine why I didn't
know you liked it so much and then re
like not even recently it was after that
I was like oh Eric loves Wicked why
didn't he put top five love that so I
have there are photos of me from high
school where I had like five shirts that
I wore on rotation and four of them were
like plays play shirts shirts that we
made for to promote our plays that from
past years and then the fifth one was a
wicked shirt it just was the logo Wicked
with a little green alphaba for the dot
on the eye my God I wore it everywhere I
listened to the Wicked soundtrack uh I
when my parents took me to go tour
colleges in the Northeast we went by New
York and I said we have to get tickets
to Wicked oh my god um I saw shashana
bean I wasn't able to see the original
cast witha and um I mean I've listened
to it enough yeah so uh and I've read
the book I read Gregory Maguire's weird
weird book where they a tiger in
the Emerald City so it's a strange book
and I'm so excited for this movie I'm so
happy for you I hope it's every I think
it's going to be great like I be beyond
all the controversy of the actors that
are in the
movie can we talk about that for a
second do you think it's so to brief our
viewers Ariana Grande is playing galinda
Upland and she has had a relationship
with the actor they cast as Bach who in
the story of wicked is like a college um
fellow student with them who has a huge
crush on Glinda but he ends up settling
for alaba's younger sister Nessa Rose
who's in a wheelchair um and she's like
the Wicked Witch of the East or whatever
um and Glenda is like see that
tragically beautiful girl the one in the
chair it seems so unfair we should go
about free and not
she uh I know someone would be my hero
if that's someone were to go invite her
and um and Box's like oh I'll get your
attention by dating this one and then he
always feels spurned so they cast this
guy who played SpongeBob on Broadway
he's a very talented actor but he's also
married and has a a young child and
basically his ex-wife went out against
Ariana Grande and said she is not a
girls girl she she's a home wrecker
and then uh I mean this this ex-wife
Ethan Slater and her had went to uh high
school together they were like High
School Musical Theater nerds together
and but now I'm wondering was this all
some kind of star kid drama you
know that once you just said that I'm
like oh my God it is such a theater kid
drama it's such theater kids not only
are they horny as hell I was a theater
kid I'm allowed to say this drama in our
we just have to create it we have to be
in it that's who we are we're bred to do
it but that that entire series that
scenario is so insane and that's all
happening especially because Ariana also
hung out with them a bunch of times with
the wife um insane and then there's
Cynthia of varia who has her own
quarrels and godamn it God we God and
then Cynthia is in the comments of
Ariana gr being like you're good girl we
got this and I'm like I don't know
what's going on but this is one of my
favorite musicals and y'all better not
ruin it for me they're not it's going to
be a two-part it's a John Chu directed
Extravaganza uh Jeff Goldblum is playing
the Wizard Michelle yo is playing Madam
moral Bowen Yang is in it this is going
to be wild this is going to be crazy
it's gonna be so much fun um and
speaking of billion dooll movies I made
a conspiracy theory video this week
about the possibility that Ryan Reynolds
could be trying to uh hijack the Super
Bowl in order to make Deadpool 3 a
billion dollar movie to um pull some
strings and get Taylor Swift to be in
the movie and that Taylor Swift is
dating Travis Kelce and the NFL is in on
it and everyone went in the comments of
that video and thought it was like a
joke or thought it was a slow news day
to me ladies and gentlemen this is a
huge news story how can you say this is
a slow news story if if if we had Loki
and Ahsoka and a Marvel movie all
happening this week I would still be
like no we got to make a video about
this this is a crazy social media
phenomenon that is happening right now
and we have to talk about and it's not a
joke it is it was honestly watch the
video I know the title of it makes the
video look stupid but I think the video
I'm proud of the video and our editors
did some amazing work in that video Eric
did do a lot of research that I could
not help with uh I don't know Taylor
Swift but uh he knows Taylor Swift he's
best friends with Taylor Swift but no he
does go into research and what I think
it's like there's so much Social things
that are happening currently like even
pop culture-- wise that we should be
talking about because it does actually
Branch into what we do in our jobs and
I'm like we're trying to also talk about
it it's not just it's not slow it's like
this actually is incorporated into what
we're doing um it's still it's just it's
more it feels more pop culture than it
does NERD fandom esque but it's still
like no it is it's part of my job like
throughout covid uh a big part of what
we did on new rock stars was a series
called tweet down uh which I would look
at a tweet of someone like you know
Elizabeth Olen and then we would use
that to speculate on whether this could
be like hinting at clues or did Ryan
Reynolds like this thing like this is
part of our our DNA at new rock stars is
to dig into this stuff and while yes we
are people who analyze movies and TV by
breaking down trailers which I feel like
is also a big part of what we do we look
at marketing strategies and this whole
thing with Ryan Reynolds and Taylor
Swift is a marketing strategy at the end
of the day um and that's as much part of
the narrative as these movies themselves
M so I don't think it's bad to say what
could Marvel Studios be hiding in this
trailer what might they have edited out
of this trailer uh in the same way I
don't think it's bad to say hey Ryan
Reynolds tweeted this and could there be
a connection to Taylor Swift in this I
think people just like it's just code
because they don't want to hear about
Taylor Swift yeah before we go let's
talk about what we're watching Jessica
what have you been watching this week
week I'm actually and we talked about
this briefly this morning I should have
saved it for this uh I'm rewatching Luke
Cage right
now I I think I'm going to go back and
wa rewatch all of the defender Saga uh
yes because I love it mainly because I
love it but I was like with the
political scheming that uh Wilson Fisk
is getting into and how we ended Luke
Cage I was like let me go back and
rewatch Luke Cage so I'm watching it
right now uh first season halfway
through very fun to rewatch it brings up
memories from so long ago that I love so
much all the actors are phenomenal and
Eric knew this I completely forgot how
many characters were returning that were
in season one of Luke Cage that have
been in Marvel property or Marvel
projects as either the same character or
a new character there's a lot of black
actors in that show that show up through
the MCU and I just completely forgot so
go back and watch it those fight scenes
the choreography great I love Harlem
that's what I'm watching right now uh
season one Luke Cage pretty good um the
once they got I mean the as long as
mahel Ali is still part of it once you
know we move on from that it to me it
it's not as good do you that's yeah I
feel the same way which I think everyone
does uh the I also I was obsessed with
it so much I went to the Creator's Tik
to or not Tik Tok Twitter account and he
uh someone mentioned how in Luke Cage
he's always fighting like a lot of brown
people it's never a lot of white people
and they were like well the Creator was
like I wanted to hire more black people
for the show and also it's Harlem and
then he also goes in to talk about how
in the pilot episode a white person
doesn't talk for the first 12 minutes
and then doesn't have a full sentence
until 20 minute 29 in the pilot and I
was like oh my God and then I watched it
and it's true it is very true it's a
crazy thing that the Creator hid a lot
of Easter eggs of himself into the show
and it's great yeah it's great I I
believe back in Fall 2017 I think I did
do a breakdown of Luke Cage season 1 but
you know what Luke Cage Jessica Jones
all these shows over the next you know
18 months two years we're going to try
to like do re breakdowns of all these
things because they're good I watched a
very very white movie called anatomy of
a
fall but it's it's February 1 it's well
hey I watched it in January I got I got
I got to it in January I would not watch
that in feu no it's it's a good movie it
was one of these movies that you saw
like mentioned at the Golden Globes and
I was like what the hell is this movie
Why is it beating all these other things
how good can it be and Kelly and I
watched it and it's just like a
wonderful like um European true crime
movie that is so well structured and you
know as we were watching I was like this
is kind of slow but then as it ended I
was like I'm fascinated by this movie's
construction and it's just like probably
the most airtight True
Crime um like legal drama that you could
ever conceive of and then when you read
the script the script is written with
like sketches of the actual layout of
the house and as you're watching it like
someone whoever wrote this must have
like conceived of every possible
permutation of how this could be it's
like uh the best episode of Law and
Order SVU or the best True Crime podcast
that you've ever listened to put into a
film and it's just really interesting
it's really really interesting now I'm
gonna watch it but I will warn you it's
like one of these movies that's over two
hours there's a lot of long takes and as
you're watching it you're going to be
like this is sleep
and but then on the other end of it
you're going to be like wow this is
really good so
anyway that's why I watch this
week but I watched it in January okay
there you go good thank you thank God
thank God we'll leave it there for this
episode of the sneak peek but let us
know which Super Bowl trailer you're
most looking forward to what movie in
2024 you're most looking forward to and
uh what do you think the greatest threat
uh Daredevil born again will bring into
the MCU I want to thank uh co-host
Jessica Clemens for joining us this week
uh follow her at Lulu Clemens you can
follow me at EAB boss support new
rockstars by grabbing a a shirt like we
have this Multiverse tour eras tour
inspired shirt that you can grab at nerd
rot. shop and be sure to get tickets to
our live show in Los Angeles on February
15th we would love to hang out with you
uh we'll see you all next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]